a lots at stake when Britain votes on
quitting the European Union the remain
campaign led by Prime Minister David
Cameron has hammered away on the costs
of brexit slower growth broken alliances
diminished influence Boris Johnson the
most popular spokesman for the leave
campaign says it's all about sovereignty
will Britain govern itself or be ruled
from Brussels the polls say it's close
and there's a reason both sides in the
debate oh right
whatever Britain does it will regret it
Britain depends on the EU for 44% of his
exports 48% of its investment from
abroad study after study says brexit
will cost what's worse Europe won't make
brexit easy anti-eu feeling is strong in
France the Netherlands and many other
countries that you will want to
discourage other rebels the remain
campaign has overplayed the doom and
gloom but it's basically right about the
dangers trouble is the leave campaign is
also right the EU does infringe
sovereignty it's meant to it's a
political project pledged to ever closer
Union Europe has a parliament an
executive and a Supreme Court the
institutions of a nation-state over time
the ties will strengthen an eeveelution
most Brits are sure to resent unlike
France Italy in Germany Britain doesn't
see the European project as a way to
come to terms with a terrible past
it's proud of its history like the u.s.
is proud and no more likely than the
u.s. to ever become people will rule
from abroad Brits are pragmatic I'm
still betting they'll do the sensible
thing on June 23rd but then repent their
timidity and hate the EU all the more